hey everybody and welcome to a very
special
wild ride with stevo what can i say
we're on a roll
big stars on the show and this episode
we're giving you a little glimpse into
what happens
before the show starts yeah dude
check it out yo what up yeah
dude [ __ ] right on [ __ ] time like
a bro
so killer man hey i keep the schedule
man i'm a professional hell yeah dude
where are you at man are you where are
you in like a rv that's right
dude we [ __ ] we do it we do it in an
rv oh yeah
what color do we want to give you give
me some red man
oh my god i got you man messed up
bandana man
i'm uh concealing some there we go
all right dude let's not waste anybody's
time over here we'll dive right in you
ready
all right okay this is how we do it
ladies and gentlemen rob durdick
yeah dude thank you for having me dude
thank you for joining us
i don't know if you've ever met my
co-host scott randolph
how's it going and upfront good to meet
you good to meet you
up front in the rv we've got paul
briskey hey rob how are you
yo what's up paul what's going on i roll
with hot dudes man what can i say
i would expect nothing less
hell yeah dude so dude thank you so much
for doing this
uh hey can i bring up a sub the subject
of breaking your ankle real quick
sure like i just want you to know that
ken block tried to get me to like
stand on a ladder and let him slide
through
and have me like like jump off and and i
got there and i'm like i
[ __ ] like i'm not [ __ ] breaking an
ankle over this [ __ ]
yeah and like i [ __ ] he was so bummed
had the whole thing set up and i
wouldn't do it
yeah and then fast forward where you
[ __ ] grab a board and are [ __ ]
gonna boneless through a [ __ ] car
like and it still it still blows my mind
that you did
so many clean clean ones
and then got the wonky fall one that got
it but i
i i it reminds me of why i'm glad i also
never did it
for sure dude for people who maybe don't
know what rob is talking about
my idea was to uh stand on a wooden out
house
i was thinking [ __ ] full eight feet
tall
and i think initially it was just i was
gonna be on the outhouse
and uh and our boy danny wade drove a
car crashing through it with me on the
roof
and it would just drop me to the ground
i did it with just sitting on it
at one point [ __ ] fell down i was
like dude [ __ ] that i got this dude i'm
gonna [ __ ] jump a skateboard off the
boat
while the car crashes through the
port-a-potty did it a bunch of times we
went through like three or four
port-a-potties
and then uh we were down to the last one
and i was like
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] stick this landing i'm gonna
and i wasn't even on the board but i
thought i was and i just fought to
[ __ ] stick the landing and all i did
was just
shatter my ankle oh man
it's still hard for me to even just
just any time you see that foot just
l-shaped yes it's like it's the worst
thing to see
you know i think that like generally
people
have a pretty easy time looking at their
own injuries
but more difficult time looking at
like really gruesome injuries of others
or i might have that wrong
but i'm saying that i'm skateboard
injuries are tougher for me
because it's like way more in like like
where
things could happen to me like something
that that's in my line of fire that's
more spooky to me to look at
than something that's just kind of even
though full scarred level bone breaks
we don't put them on ridiculousness
right like
like even if you do shatter something
you can't tell right like because it's
like
any time you see that snap it's just
it's just a little
a little bit too it loses it's fun right
right you know
for all the pro skateboarders and and uh
action sports
stars that we've had on here we've
generally made a point to ask
about their uh their their surgeries
they're like have you have you just
where like where are you is between tony
hawk and danny way
well look here's the thing about danny
west he loves surgery
okay danny way [ __ ] just
goes under local anesthesia and talks
through the [ __ ] surgery with the
doctors
you know what i mean like to him he's
like oh i got injured again let's do
surgery it's a [ __ ] entirely
different experience
you know i only i only had in my entire
career and this is through
20 years of professional skateboarding
and
uh all the years of fantasy factory and
doing all the crazy stunts
the only thing i ever had surgery on was
to remove a bone spur
in my ankle like never only broke one
arm and broke a couple fingers but never
once had
any significant injuries by the grace of
god
yeah in that entire you know 25-year run
yeah you and tony hawk man that's great
dude
look man i still look tony will slam
like every
year year and a half in some crazy way
you know and every like he you know he
just did one recently where he like
knocked himself out like trying some
some trick on like the vertex like
and as the as i get older and he gets
older and i see these [ __ ]
these once in a blue moon mega slams
they they hurt even worse when i see him
yeah
i did i did this double wall ride with
tony
not long ago we pushed two ramps up
against the wall with one landing ramp
he had the bigger one
so simultaneously we did the wall he
wall ride over my wall ride that makes
sense
and uh [ __ ] dude he slammed so hard on
that one dude
i was like i killed tony maybe that's
the one that i saw
i was blown away that you were able to
wall ride so easily
what thanks because running up onto like
running up full
vertical wall it's still you know it's
still real
dude you know i pride myself oh [ __ ] i
never hit the
the the [ __ ] time out whatever dude i
got this cool clock to time our [ __ ]
you're just talking about it too i know
yeah when tony slammed dude you know he
was [ __ ] up when you're just tapping
your foot on the ground
his foot starts twitching he's not
getting up
dude is the worst um but yeah dude
so you said 25 years i mean i i
so you started when you're old sixteen
turned
pro when i was sixteen so again
but i kind of blended that pro career
into
um like you know the tv side you know
what i mean where i
and i started selling so much more
product and skating less
but you know was had more and more skate
[ __ ] because of the tv profile
sure and and uh my very first sponsor
was xyz clothing and
i like one of your first sponsors was
xyz skate supply which was the same
thing right
yeah that was before they tried that was
when it was like tommy and danny's like
side hustle skate shot yeah garage
and i think like your era
like i want to say that was pretty close
to the face catching on fire yeah
right like sure like right after that
zone
and you just connected with the tommy
tommy's like almost like a jeff tremaine
almost right
you know like he's just he's the
together smart guy but almost like the
institutor too
and yeah and like and i knew like that
sort of world
um is where it all started because even
when i started coming out to california
from ohio i would go and stay in
carlsbad
and that's really how i got to to know
danny
and those guys back then but danny was
so much different back then you know
what i mean like
back then like you couldn't even talk to
him you know what i mean like he would
[ __ ] walk into the
like man i remember i was already on dc
for like
like and had like two signature shoes
and he had barely even started talking
to me back then
for as he evolved and had kids and
became one of my really good friends
like but back then then it was like
super danny like megalomaniac
crazy danny and that and that especially
in the xyz era
but weren't you there in 1997 when he
first
uh set the higher record like uh
he jumped out of the helicopter every
single one of them
right so i got to go [ __ ] i went
uh you know to hard rock to jump off the
guitar i went to china to jump the great
wall
i was there for the very first high air
i was i look
we went [ __ ] we had a lunch in a
cafeteria
and he mentioned something about a
helicopter and i said well i don't
understand
what you're saying though he's like no
i'm not we're going to jump off the
helicopter into the ramp
and i'm like what the [ __ ] like
yeah and then next thing you know lunch
is over and [ __ ] everybody's like
and he's [ __ ] hanging off the edge of
the [ __ ] helicopter to jump in it's
like
i've always been mind blown because i
feel like
him him laird and travis pastrana all
have this like weird
malfunctioned where they don't fear
doesn't
they don't connect with fear they
connect with
execution so like they're not like
they're only thinking about god how
amazing would it be to jump off this
helicopter versus like and and only
thinking about execution where anytime
i've ever done anything dangerous it's
like all i'm thinking about is like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] am i doing why am i doing
this [ __ ]
all right let's just [ __ ] get it done
right like oh yeah
of course we've been talking about tommy
who started
xyz which was which was uh integral
in our early careers and tommy says that
back in the day when you were
uh part of the xyz skate supply thing
he says dude back then derdick was a
daryl they're just
drunk and smoking weed and [ __ ] and uh
and then it wasn't until uh
he you went to this uh dr pratt
dr pratt who was a a hypnotist
that hypnotist is something else man rob
credits this person with making him a
business
assassin and i gotta tell you what
and who i credit for making me a fitness
assassin it's called whoop right
this fitness tracker i wear on my right
wrist
it connects with this app which gives me
helpful information like
i'm working on 97 recovery right now
what does that mean it means i better
get on my bicycle
and do some kind of serious workout even
though i'm recovering from a couple
injuries
like two plates in my shoulder and
this thing that happened to my hip look
i'm a mess
okay but my whoop bands telling me it's
time to work out because i have strong
recovery man and that's what this is all
about dude this thing
tells you when you sleep how much you
sleep what kind of sleep you get how
much your body recovers
how much strain you should be taking on
and then when you do take on strain
man i go surfing i don't know how to put
anything in the app it's like oh yeah
you went surfing boom it logs my
activity i get on my bicycle it knows
you went cycling it tells me how my
workout went
keeps me motivated to keep going and
that's why at the back end of my 40s
i'm looking good feeling good and i want
you to look better and feel better
yourself
so you're gonna go to woop.com
use the promo code stevo you get 15
off at checkout once again for your woop
membership
you're going to get 15 off if you go to
woop.com
and use the promo code stevo yeah dude
i would probably put it in
you know i got so much success early
right turned pro quickly you know got
everything we're moved to cali dc
happened all this stuff
and but i also just partied
so much right like not not like
you know you know deep heavy uh stevo
level days
right but like you know i was
i was burning away the career but what i
ultimately burned away with that
was like self-belief right like i
i i really then ended up like
questioning myself and like could i even
still be pro and
and do i even have what is my life going
to be like
what if i'm not a pro skateboarder
anymore right which was
hammered by ken block saying
uh you know when i was 24 that like we
think your best years are behind you
and we're gonna give you one more uh uh
two-year contract
uh before you retire right so it was
just like i just
partied my way into [ __ ] being
retired
and i went to george pratt
on this idea of he wrote this book hyper
success
and he was a hypnotist and this is back
in the phone book days
i was just looking through the [ __ ]
phone book because there was no [ __ ]
internet of like oh clinical
psychologist like hypnotist right i'm
like oh this is at la jolla scripps this
is legit
and and he the first test he did on me
was like you don't believe you were
meant your subconscious doesn't believe
you are meant to be successful
and then lo and behold we did a handful
of sessions and
and i never i've never taken a step
backwards
never again in my life right and maybe i
was ready maybe i
that was my moment in time like and i
was ready to like find and regroup
but i had since you know took all my
friends there i take my wife there
i just celebrated my fifth year uh
wedding anniversary and did a full
wedding in eohi
he did the ceremony yeah i mean like
that's
you know all these years later i still
look at him as this
sort of you know at least integral piece
of just
you know being this this this conduit
that took me to this entirely other
level dude epic man do you keep going
back
to refresh with him like or you're still
rocking off that
initial you know i don't all all like
you know i said um you know i saw him
not that long glass i just want to
like verify that my subconscious
believes i'm going to be a billionaire
uh and he's like you know does some like
mad he's like stop
you already know that anyway
you know for me i also have done so much
deep work on my subconscious
and basically clearing out so much
aspect
that i live in this like super super
sharp
presence with like super clear long
term goals so i ended up in sort of this
like
this state where i don't really question
much
and sort of attract all of the things
that i need to perpetuate me towards
those long-term goals
so it worked where'd you get the sense
enough to look for a hypnotist
like when ken block told you you know
you're going to retire like what made
you
go through the phone book and be like i
think a hypnotist is what i need right
now
i don't that's a really [ __ ] very valid
and straightforward normal question
right like what the [ __ ] why and when
you say it to me i'm like well god damn
it what was the strategy
i know i'm [ __ ] up i need someone to
hypnotize me to not [ __ ] up you know i
don't know
he said some daryl [ __ ]
i went through him i went to him the
test to stop biting my nails and it
worked for a week and then i haven't
been able to stop biting my nails
the last 20 years so i don't know what
the answer is
two different stories two different
stories
so going back to then you know you see
you see
dr pratt and uh then
like your your what year was it you saw
dr pratt you think
well [ __ ] if i was 25 so that was 20
21 years ago right so or maybe 24 so 22
years ago
so you know like late 90s right 97 98
took a huge right because then you know
i had
hip-hop labels and you know stay i was
doing all types of businesses and all
types of stuff
and it also i've refocused on my
state career only and then
like you know when i told ken block in
that meeting i said look in two years
i will be a completely different person
and
at the end of that two years i was like
top 10 in the world in
every single contest like i grinded the
20 stair handrail
for the mtv commercial like i had just
like literally
it rededicated my life to skateboarding
and then like
completely like re-engineered re
re completely invigorated my career then
i would
only sign two-year deals right and i
said because every two years i'm gonna
be even bigger and better and that led
to then robin big
then only a two-year deal and then
fantasy factory only a two-year deal
like i
i did all of that until i finally signed
a 10-year deal
and then they went out of business yeah
yeah
so now my
like this is just i love that you say
that because i'm replacing where you saw
dr pratt in 1998
and then two years after that you said
and then you had it together
that's your 2000 year 2000
was uh when i worked in the circus but
right before i worked in the circus
i went out to uh [ __ ] tampa
the tampa pro contest and i went out
there on some harebrained idea i'm going
to set myself on fire in the middle of
the street course which i totally did
and while i was there [ __ ] if
that whole pro contest this is the most
prestigious
biggest profile skateboard contest put
on by skaters
in the world the biggest event of the
year and rob durden you
dominated that for the whole [ __ ]
time they were just like
first place qualifier [ __ ] just
killing it all over the place man like
you i've never seen anybody dominate a
contest the way you dominated that
tamper pro and i mean it's all anybody
was talking about
[ __ ] badass and look and and tampa's
like you know
you know it's this dirty schaefer and
the homies and the shitty dirty [ __ ]
it's
[ __ ] saw the pros start throwing the
[ __ ] skateboards and the product into
the muddy moat
to watch all the [ __ ] little kids
wrestle in the mud to get the
[ __ ] product it just never met like
it always was what mattered the most
and totally you know like even though it
had the lowest prize money
and like at least it was still like the
[ __ ] thing that mattered the most
because even even we shot a robin big
episode
and it was a battle of me and steve
barra
uh for five g's on who could do the
building i hadn't entered a contest in
you know probably six or seven years
when we shot that right what was that
over who could do what it was whoever
placed it was a five thousand dollar bet
of whoever placed
higher okay and then
uh in that episode and what i did is i
watched the amateur contest
i watched their runs over and over and i
would go to the park
and just try my run based off of what
until my body would break down
then i would go home i just did it i
hadn't skated a contest in
literally six or seven years and then
just did that same run
all the way through and got like sixth
place it was like
you know after not being at it for all
those years
and it's like it's like the highlight of
my
skateboard career you know what i mean
just being able to like make the top 10
after all the years of not even skating
why yeah please
steve bear is a dangerous guy to play
that game with because he's the dude who
just never skated
at all and then put down his board and
kick flip 50 50 the round rail like
he's an anomaly where it's like what the
[ __ ] dude
the dude just speaks too rarely
yeah bear is epic man um so
that's it i remember that so much being
there in person at the tampa pro contest
and i remember also you emerging
with like this persona almost in
skateboarding
of i called you the puff daddy
of skateboarding you know and like and
to qualify that statement like
you know skateboarders weren't were
like hashers you know it was like oh
we're gnarly we're thrashers you know
there was
there was no such thing that i was
really aware of
in skateboarding of like a skateboarder
like
flossing you know i mean sure tony hawk
had
in the end you know they showed his
lexus and his nice house and stuff
but that wasn't there wasn't like uh it
just wasn't a vibe of skateboarding you
were the first one
to do like yo i'm posing with the on the
cover with the [ __ ] luxury [ __ ]
mercedes and the
the crazy exotic animal and you know
like like you were flossing
and that was like that was almost your
like niche on it and then you know the
way that you describe
rob and big came out of this whole thing
i think there's a pretty important piece
missing there
which is the first dc video it came out
in 2003
and you had this absolutely [ __ ]
genius
like sort of a gimmick for your part
where you said dude
[ __ ] skateboarding [ __ ] security
getting getting nailed by foot trying to
deal with security
i'm so sick of dealing with security i
got security to
deal with security and that was that was
how
big came into the picture and it was
such a [ __ ] genius thing it was such
an
excellent part that whole dc video was
so magnificent
and of course that served as the proof
of concept
for what would be the robin big show
right like that i mean
yeah did you basically just show them
that as a in your pitch
like here's what it is it was um you
know first of all in the flossing thing
just to
just to make a note because it was boy
you want to ruffle some [ __ ] feathers
you start flossing and skateboarding
right and it was like and now it's the
norm
now everyone it was like it set the
stage for you know
this young generation that like like you
know they all
are cars and watches and everything but
that was like some f
what the [ __ ] is going on here level
[ __ ] and
it peaked with the big brother [ __ ]
cover
of [ __ ] putting the bends on on the
cover now of course
i bought ken block's bands i bought you
know i mean i still
the feeling of driving that thing out of
his house when i got was the first like
mega nice car that i ever got i'm like
oh
i bought like his iced out rolex like it
was like i got them to make iced out i
went to the
jeweler and made an iced out dc ring and
was like we need to make these for
everybody
like this like flossy run uh
that became sort of this en entire thing
is this after pratt or what totally
after prayer
oh yeah because this was like part of
like you're reinventing yourself
yeah like you and to me i i i
met this this this this kid
who had a billboard on sunset who picked
me up in a 600
uh um s-class benz
that had a fax machine in it and i was
like goddamn this [ __ ] guy
this guy must be the the richest guy
i've ever met like and he was just like
like this 19 year old hustler
right who like he just it it affected me
in the way of this power of perception
right where like you can create this
persona
uh that goes way beyond like who you are
as a business person or athlete or so i
thought in my
as i as i developed that whole thing you
know
um it just got really over the top
really fast especially as it related to
like me and colin
and and sort of like ev and kareem and
everybody that really embraced
like flossing to like a whole different
there was so much pressure on me on the
dc video
everybody was so gnarly and i just knew
that like [ __ ]
man i just i'm never gonna be able to
film a part to sit next to all these
guys like they're all filming the
[ __ ] gnarliest parts like
you know i i like to say i've made the
most money
per trick landed in the history of
skateboarding
how many bail photos i've had and how
the limited amount of [ __ ] footage
i've actually generated
but like i conceptually
as i was like trying to think like oh my
god it would be funny to come up with a
skit
and then when it was like just the idea
of i'm gonna bring a security guard
to deal with security guards just just
connected so
quickly and then even when we we we just
went to like a security agency in san
diego we're like we're just looking for
like
a really lovable like big cool they're
like oh we got the perfect guy
wow that's how you met big yeah it was
like literally
didn't weren't friends at all was like a
straight like casted from a
security agency in the day we met to
shoot it
it was just like instant like oh we you
know we just
instantly were in it and like already
like
improving and doing the most ridiculous
stuff
um that set the stage but it was really
like look me and him would
man i broke my arm one year and
in that era before before tv and all
that [ __ ] i mean
because he rolled with big zeus and big
bam bam
right so he had like this trio of mega
men
and then we would roll together so we
would roll to vegas
and all put on suits and [ __ ] they
would be like it would just be us three
and everybody was like convinced i was
like some sort of like
super wealthy billionaire you know like
you know when we were pitching the show
i was telling them a story of how
we went to vegas and there was a roy
jones jr fight and i was like [ __ ] it
like just let's just try to get in
so i walked up with all three of them i
said excuse me ma'am i don't have the
ticket but i'm going to pass if you
don't mind it's like oh go right ahead
right you don't just have to take it
from rob
durdick that there are certain things
you can do which will get you special
treatment you can take it from
me and my friends at manscapes
that if you groom your balls and your
body properly it's safe to say
you might get special treatment from the
ladies
and here we are this close to the
holidays to christmas
and have you really not taken care of
all of your christmas shopping yet
well the good news is that manscaped
is your home for the dopest
stocking stuffers what am i talking
about i'm talking about how much
joy it brings dudes to reach into their
stocking and pull out
the crop preserver ball
deodorant i mean that's a good laugh for
everybody and
they got the crop reviver
ball toner i mean these are the under
the waist
grooming products that every man needs
and you can hurry up and get them right
now in time for the holidays
to start stuff those stockings okay so
here's how we get them we go to
manscaped.com
that takes care of your holiday shopping
plus you get 20
off your order and free shipping that's
20 off your order and free shipping
manscaped.com stevo
now let's hear about special treatment
it's like just straight on that power
perception like we all [ __ ] roll down
it's just working
and i [ __ ] walk all the way down to
like four seats from the [ __ ] ring i
said man if you don't mind
we're gonna sit right here she said oh
go go right ahead and we just [ __ ]
watched the roy jones junior fight all
four of us
yeah and chicks kept coming up to me
like hey can i give him my number
and it's like just just because
it was like one little dude surrounded
by these three giant guys
how we sort of positioned and tried to
to drive the show as like
hey the um the odd couple you know even
when i took the show to pitch it in it
was like i took in the song people let
me tell you about my
best friend but they wouldn't buy that
show
right it was when mtv was stealing like
we need scripts and you know and even
jeff
wasn't really connected to being able to
ultimately write scripts in that type of
production
and they ended up buying the show rob
deardex rules to success
and rule number one was always surround
yourself with good people
that was the pilot and this was
a big black was like the person you
surround yourself with right i was so
whack
and we shot the pilot it was [ __ ] except
for when i go off script
and we were we were going the script and
then we we started freestyling a little
bit about where he said he could outrun
me
if we were in prison he could catch me
i'm like you ain't [ __ ] catching me
first of all and then it turned into you
couldn't even [ __ ]
like you couldn't beat me in a foot race
and then it's like let's [ __ ] go
right then it turned that freestyle
moment
became sort of the anchor of like okay
we'll let these guys
get off like stop forcing them to be in
a script and let them go
and then shane nickerson
came over because he was a story editor
from the the
jessica simpson show and then he pieced
it together and was like you need to
just let these guys be themselves
and then it circled all the way back to
rob and big
for the pilot you know so you didn't so
you didn't have to make a pilot
for the rob durdix rules of success
you know we shot it and then midway
through and all the pickups they
reshaped it
into robin big right and it was
originally robin big black and the
network
wouldn't let it be big black and it was
like a black woman that was running the
network at the time
and like you know we had to call her and
she was like absolutely not
and and in the beginning like when we
would hear rob and big
you know it you know would be like if if
jackass what call
what's called jackay yeah
it's like i guess i guess right you know
like the
because we only knew it like he was big
black he wasn't big
right so it was like super strange for
us in the beginning where it was like
rather big sounds so weird and so that
if if i'm right robin big came out
was it 2007 maybe 2006. it was like
right at the end of 2006 so right in
right and so that's when your [ __ ]
starts
really popping off yeah well look you
want to know what i also did
is i saw what was happening to all of
bam's products
oh yeah right yeah so bands pro so i was
like god damn it man
so i did a deal with dc renegotiated for
a higher royalty i restructured my
uh board deal with alien workshop
to be like give me five dollars a board
and give me 2 000 a month instead of two
dollars a board
and uh five thousand a month like
restructure with them
started uh rogue status with travis
barker
uh did did position myself to have all
of these sort of opportunities if it
worked
that then i would be able to capitalize
on it based off of what i saw
what was happening with ban and then
boom it just exploded
overnight you know i mean yeah bam set
the
the precedent right there when you've
already got the revenue stream from the
pro skateboarding and then you attach a
rocket ship to it with the mainstream tv
show
then uh you're off to the races um and
it's crazy that the
industry standard for royalties to the
pro skateboarders two bucks a board
that's [ __ ] what does the board cost
normally a board costs
17 well 17 to make to sell or whatever
35 is 30 now maybe like 40 50 i don't
know it's been so long
wow worst thing i ever did was buy a
skateboard company
oh yeah you know what look i bought that
i spent four
million when i bought that company and i
bought a workshop
yeah and i bought dna distribution it
was such a nightmare
of like just like the
the skateboarding loves misery like
nobody wants anything to like be
bit like just insanity that i ended up
giving the company back to the original
founders
and then having it i bought a bunker
which i still own to this day
in dayton ohio on a full military grade
bunker on six acres of land and i let
them
put the company back into that and just
was like all right i'm
out like and that was like my last skate
business before i
sold street league last year
was like the final final time final time
of me as a capitalist
and someone that [ __ ] loves creating
venture and making money
of trying to instill that spirit into
skateboarding which
it's not meant to be you know what i
mean and from flossing
[ __ ] in 2003 to [ __ ] start you
know everything i did was how do we make
skateboarding mega and it was
literally not ever meant to be man
so uh well i got a question you you have
this entrepreneurial mind but it sounds
like
you were kind of thinking that way
before the hypnotism right you were
saying you had like a hip-hop label and
different things you were doing
that's pre-hypnotism oh yeah yeah i
started i was raised by entrepreneur
wolves right like all the
all the people like you know the guys
that started the alien workshop i've
known since they were 13 since i was 13
jimmy george in dayton ohio he's one of
the original founding partners he built
all these
these different companies i worked i
skated for his skate shop and
and saw him build all these companies
when i moved to california i built my
first company
orion trucks with costing and guy and
green
that's still going strong right yeah
like i look i was reading the book the
orion prophecies back then it was about
you know all these [ __ ] messaging
coming from the [ __ ] orion
prophecies and i hand drew the logo and
me and kareem and um uh
costing were the original partners in it
with
tracker which was also like a pretty big
deal of like
you know all the venture norcal guys
were so pissed at me that
i would do a company with tracker uh and
and that was the first company that i
had built
from idea stage to market when i was 17
right wow and then i went on i was
building company after company with that
shoe money
all types of stuff but i didn't i was i
didn't understand business
because i was someone that quit high
school at 16 and didn't have a family or
that understood like business i was just
around entrepreneurs so i figured [ __ ]
i'm gonna do this too you know
right i think the answer to paul's
question might be yes
rob was starting a lot of businesses
before the hypnotists
but a number of the businesses were
losing money
right so it was good yeah what that's
how you learned though
i spent many years of businesses i don't
think i really figured out how to be
the the type of business assassin that i
am today
you know not even you know five six
years ago you know i mean deep
deep into my late 30s into my 40s you
know
right um so you go
from from robin big then he got the
fantasy factory
and the fan what was what was the do you
still have the fantasy factor
is that no no no and you know for
that that whole thing was ultimately i
was so sick of [ __ ]
shooting tv in my house yeah and was so
[ __ ] sick of people coming to my
house all the time you know and
and and it being in that zone but what i
what i realized is god i just made
so much money from this platform
and you know they wanted me to do a four
season of robin big but at that point me
and him were like beefing so hard
uh you know mainly on this idea that
we felt kind of bound to each other and
lost our sort of identities right like
and
and neither of us wanted to do the show
anymore but
they had offered me at that time to give
you context 125 000 an episode
to either do uh another season of robin
big
or do my own show
and i'm i was like [ __ ] i don't want to
do my own show
and but then i realized man quit being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] man like
you just go uh do another show so i
wrote the concept
of i called it fantasy life but then i
then i realized like no i need to be
like a get a building and become like
willy wonka
and i'm gonna call that [ __ ] the fantasy
factory but i would only do it
if they also gave me my integration
rights
so i could sell the platform
um when i did it so then i was able to
do deals with my chevy and microsoft and
use the actual platform
to sell the advertising on which
really blew everything up to like an
even crazier level wow
let me take you back to the you said
they offered 125 000
an episode how much of that is talent
fee
versus producer fee because says
at that time 25 of it was producer right
like because back then you know like
producer was still
for me at least in that standpoint
before i built super jacket producer was
more
what they gave us as talent you know
what i'm saying like where they would
just
because what did what did you get at the
peak of wild boys oh my god we had the
same from the whole [ __ ] time
pontius and i each got 15 grand an
episode
right so it's like like think how nuts
that was
like and it was like damn [ __ ] it i'm
gonna do and i was like
[ __ ] it like i spent 750 g's to build
out the fantasy factory
and then midway through that season they
were like this [ __ ]
sucks we're not even gonna air this [ __ ]
and i'm like god
damn it what the [ __ ] like and
what was the rent for the promise what's
up what was the rent
like 30 grand a month 30 35 grand a
month just to like have that place you
know what i mean
and then i [ __ ] you know spent i
built i it was [ __ ] balls to the wall
no
like i built the place completely out
[ __ ] skate park
full concrete [ __ ] skatepark in a
building you know what i mean like
uh super over the top but they it was
only
they tried to make it robin big with my
cousin drama
rather than integrating all the people
that were in the
business side of my business my manager
and
and and sort of my my lawyer and artists
and everyone involved in my companies
and when i went back and looked at some
of the cuts the very first cuts where it
integrated all of them
like we re-pitched the show of like this
is a group
not just me and my cousin we gotta quit
trying to make robin big
and that's when it became um what it
became but that's now
now i'm doing [ __ ] stunts right
because i was never a stunt guy i'm a
business guy
but i wrote a bowl in robin big
and started to open up the juice a
little bit
right and then in that first episode
uh tremaine i was making a joke about
getting attacked by a shark and tremaine
was like oh i got a place that'll do it
in the bahamas
and so next thing you know i'm [ __ ]
in a chain suit
in the [ __ ] 60 feet under [ __ ]
water with a [ __ ] piece of tuna on my
arm
thinking like do i really want to
[ __ ] lose function over my arm this
isn't even
funny yeah i feel like you got to be
careful what you say around jeff
tremaine is that true
was that the blue it was kind of like
the blue cove or the blue lagoon or
whatever yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah what is that yeah yeah we went
through them
yeah it said it's so funny yeah it's
sharks man sharks have been my thing
and you're right they're not even
[ __ ] funny
hey but diving look even did you hey did
you ever
die with the great whites in guadalupe
not guadalupe we did it in
south africa south africa yeah and now
did you
did you jump on the back or was that
ponies it was both of us we didn't jump
on the back because if you jump
on the shark that would have been like
uh cruelty to animals so
what we did was we jumped next to it we
jumped we landed right in between the
shark and the cage
and then climbed the cage very quickly
yeah so
how many seasons did you do fantasy
factory i did
eight designs even in that zone
like in and i did the final season and
then i
they i ended up doing this mega deal
with ridiculousness and they're like the
only reason
only way we'll do it is if you do
another season of
fantasy factory so now i did the [ __ ]
final final season you know what i'm
saying
i don't know i'm sure are you are you
filming a
jackass somehow are you even allowed to
talk about it
uh but i'm i'm not sure it feels that
way to you now you might love this [ __ ]
but that [ __ ] final season when i was
[ __ ] doing stuff like
it was like oh my god i'm here again
like it was like
on some like get the [ __ ] out of here
and the final the final thing i did is i
jumped
uh a monster truck 43 uh 40 feet through
an exploding rv at monster jam in
anaheim
and then uh got out and stood on top of
that truck in front of all those [ __ ]
people like
my final scene ever and then that night
my girlfriend at the time's
dad was there and i asked him for her
hand in marriage
and then that was basically like the
transition point of like
all right i'm this this era is
officially [ __ ] over i will never do
a stunt again i'm ready to be a dad you
know
yeah right and that's why i feel so
honored to have you on this
[ __ ] podcast with us because really
since then you've become
a pretty elusive guy man right like
you're not like uh
really out you're not doing the
interviews and out in the
like right yeah i mean i stopped doing
it all together
you know what i mean like i do some
business stuff here and there but
you know and they forced me to do press
um
one time you know i had to do like a
radio tour or something you know what i
mean
because look i you know for me you know
blessing that i get
to shoot so much ridiculousness and and
what a
what a instrumental part of like my
business careers i was able to build and
sell the production company connected to
it
you know i shoot you know 168 episodes a
year
i'm shooting 250 a year for the next two
years before i double peace sign
moonwalk out of here
but you would have no idea right i heard
this [ __ ] so much you know [ __ ] maybe he
shoots 30 of a year maybe he's 40 who
[ __ ] knows they just rerun them all
the time so
it's insane it's the biggest show on mtv
and hands down by far
right but you want to know but but why
why we're able to make it so successful
is since i owned the production
i was able to negotiate the unit
economics of the cost of the show with
the head of the network
to be able to make it super profitable
for both of us
to where i could get them to order 168
at a time
instead of ordering 30 at a time right
or eight at a time like wild boys
eight right oh my god like they wanted
me to do a business show
and i [ __ ] like i when i think about
shooting like
like a season order of [ __ ] like 10
episodes i can't even [ __ ] it's like
what am i doing
i can't i don't want to [ __ ] bother
doing it try to figure out another
[ __ ] show that like
nobody wants to see me doing a business
show on [ __ ] mtv
and i just bailed you know man it's epic
now as i understand it because i
remember having a business meeting with
some
[ __ ] guy that was like talking about
facebook monitoring
everybody who's in there with the social
media oh we're gonna [ __ ] make you
this amount of money with that yeah
they're just all
it just seems shady to me every [ __ ]
time and i'm like you know
i've i've worked so hard like having a
genuine authentic [ __ ] line of
communication
with my fans that if i start [ __ ]
farming it out
to people who aren't me it's just gonna
spoil everything
you know like i just won't do it and
i've turned down like i think
insane amounts of money just like
favoring my integrity
for giving people what comes straight
from me which i deemed to be quality
[ __ ] that i made
you know but i had one i had a meeting
with one of these people
and they were like oh dude you don't get
it dude rob durdick
he [ __ ] took his ridiculousness thing
and then added in a new layer where
anybody can try to submit their video to
be
on ridiculousness and what they do is
they upload their video to rob
durdik's [ __ ] little platform thing
and
in uploading the video they click right
here like i gave rob durdick the rights
to this video
in order for it so that he's like this
is a whole other
like area of business that rob durdick
has like aside from the show
is that he just owns all this [ __ ]
video content
like is is that right
that's correct
behind hustling you because it's a
business right like it's not
a we have giant teams of people that are
that are
sourcing that and then going getting the
rights like it's it's not as simple as
like i'm sitting back [ __ ]
right right right for sure and when you
do that is it it's not like an exclusive
thing right it's like i have the
non-exclusive right or to the yeah
yeah non-exclusive it's just really
managing it it gives us a lot of
leverage on what
it is um and then we're just building
this sort of
deep library of content you know yeah
but again like even that aspect that was
you know when i i sold super jacket that
included that
and part of that deal is they bought
street leg at the same time
right so so really all those companies i
built all those companies just to be
sold and they all
uh have since been acquired is it uh
okay to ask what you sold street league
for
and before we before we even get there
to let people know what it is this is
like
like the like the gold standard of
skateboarding competition right you got
the x games you got the dude tour and
you got
the sls skateboarding
yeah and really the vision was like how
do we make you know that was you know if
tampa was the chorus then it was
you know 25 000 first prize our
our first prize was 150 grand and we
were
pouring concrete [ __ ] um
skate plazas in arenas with lighting
packages and [ __ ] jumbotrons
you know trying to fill arenas to turn
skateboarding into
the nba yeah um and
it never got the audience
um of the scale of the crossover like a
ufc got right where to me it was like
just a matter of time before it
it dips into that zone uh and never
caught quite at that scale so we didn't
really sell it for anything
significant um compared to the
production company right i just
more or less roll them in but you know
when it's all said and done it could be
there's an earn out connected to it
um but but hopefully it lands in like
150 million range at the very end you
know what i mean something in that sort
of zone
uh is sort of the goal but every time i
build a company
i build every company with the intent of
trying to sell it between
uh 75 and 150 um
and we've been able to do it five times
right in the first
first a few years of using this system
of
of creating it some some smaller some
didn't work
out some happened really fast but it's
really just getting better and better at
being able to do that is my life's
mastery at this point
[ __ ] hey dude can i get dr pratt's
number
what the [ __ ] hey we're gonna [ __ ] those
nails aren't gonna be
business and you're [ __ ] getting rich
all right i love you
we're trying our asses off over here man
i think that you kind of uh
you hit it on the head when you said you
know talking about filming jackass like
maybe you like that [ __ ] i'm like yeah
yeah but i'm trying my ass off to like
get to be
to work smarter to you know
build things like we just uh got our
first warehouse you know
to set up our own fulfillment center so
that we can let the third party
fulfillment center [ __ ] off
and uh you know like if we can run
smoothly with with just my merch
operation
then you know hallelujah because now we
can start taking on other clients and
really expand and get in this
fulfillment game and i think that that
represents like
the first initiative that really takes
away from just
attention whoring you know because i've
been a [ __ ] professional attention
[ __ ] for my whole career and uh and and
then to try to become a businessman in a
way that's
sort of savvy as this is yeah and look
and and i'll tell you what it boils down
to
is the the life that you want to live
it's the lifestyle
right it's like you got to put a target
on here's here's what it costs to live
the life that i want to live
and then how do i create a sustainable
way to produce that income
that gives me peace right um you know
because it doesn't matter how much money
i have i still
keep my expenses within the range of the
money i make from the buildings i've
invested in
right it's a tax-free cash-on-cash
dividend
like i don't even account for like tv
business anything
i look at my life through that and then
i i build up a comfortable lifestyle
through that passive income um as part
of sort of a plan that's what i needed
to kind of have that peace so i can
still
have all the energy to achieve these big
things without
ever risking the way that i live or
compromising that more
that peace that comes along with success
if you will you know
and i think if you once you land on
on exactly what that is and then you
hunt to find
the fulfillment center that produces the
support of that
that anything else you want to do is
gravy yeah
then you'll find especially when it's
not related to you
having to [ __ ] right go hurt yourself
right
and that's what i love even so much
about the uh
the the buildings that i invest in is
because it's
it has nothing to do with anything that
i do right
so it's like it's totally separate right
so it's like i could stop everything and
i live this way for the rest of my life
right like that sort of peace of mind
that comes with it that has nothing to
do with
my talent or my time right yeah or or
your your reputation or your you as a
commodity in the entertainment industry
you know you don't have to be depressed
to promote it
yeah look i mean look i stopped doing
brand deals
you know i that's like like when dc went
out i never did another shoe deal i
never did another energy drink deal i
never
what i was able to walk away from uh you
know five six years ago was also like
needing to be an endorser right so it's
like now i don't [ __ ] gotta go to
photos
i literally live the most balanced
extraordinary life of like where i do
whatever i want and
based off of what gives me energy right
versus the idea of like damn i gotta go
[ __ ]
do a monster energy [ __ ] 7-eleven
photo shoot
i got a [ __ ] you know you know some
[ __ ] i got to go to a [ __ ] zoomies
for a [ __ ] signing i mean like
that [ __ ] like was like you know and
even in that era i got this crazy offer
from airwalk
right and uh this big uh licensing group
owned air walk and it was like man i
stood on the edge
because it was so much money and then i
was like god damn it rob like
you're gonna like you've already cleaned
yourself up of
like doing like stuff that bastardizes
skateboarding and you're gonna [ __ ]
go right try to [ __ ]
go make a business deal with air walk
like you [ __ ] can't do it
that was like the big turning point of
where i
i never did another personal endorsement
deal again
and now everything that i ever showcase
is just all [ __ ] that i companies i
started right
that i just promote like things that i
built
rather than doing any type of
endorsement
work you know because that [ __ ] just
wore me out yeah
yeah dude [ __ ] man we're making progress
dude because i just found so much of the
last 10 years scott and i
the [ __ ] on tour [ __ ] with the
comedy clubs and it's like
ah this grind of groundhog's day over
and over
constantly traveling to go do this thing
you know and i love it
at the same time it's [ __ ] it's a
grind man it's not working smart
but it's not just that it's like you got
to wake up at 5 00 a.m for the press
after we land at two and then you get to
take a nap before we do shows
yeah that night of 600 people
yeah it's rough dude it's it's rough i
launched
when i launched street league right i'm
not only did i finance and build this
baby my dream to create the nba
skateboarding but dc
and monster under it in the beginning
right
so i would have to [ __ ] go into the
towns where we would have the
um where the event was seattle las vegas
forever
i have to spend 10 days there doing like
every single news station every single
radio show go to every single skate shop
every single [ __ ] zoomies
every [ __ ] 7-eleven you [ __ ] like
yeah so i
i that like was like like
i mean that twist so i feel you
on that it's way different than just
showing up and performing where it's
just like the chaos yeah people don't
know the behind the scenes i mean
meanwhile you just made three million
while you did this podcast and we're
over here
yeah yeah you know just
grinding we're still grinding there
we're just no wonder he's my
[ __ ]
dude oh my god dude what [ __ ] like is
there anything
that you're even trying to promote like
can we can we uh yeah
yeah do you have any more world records
coming up or what
not look those are all done you know
what i mean i
you know i tried when i got all those
like 25 records in a day
all i wanted was a record for the most
records in a day
because i'm like [ __ ] nobody's going to
beat that right and they wouldn't give
me that
um but no those are just i hold on to
those near and dear to my heart
um and then you know really you know i
launched a a comfort footwear brand this
week with john buscemi called lusso
cloud
i have a nootropic superfood that i
launched with their footwear
we're trying to get footwear going with
uh
customized slip-ons vans won't do it we
got
like uh we got a built from scratch
company that's super cheap but we
we want like a reputable like [ __ ]
this
this company makes it like uh can you
can we get in the business of customized
slip-ons
i don't believe this company would make
sense for that i think
they're
uh yeah i'm not i'm not saying there's
not a an opportunity there but
to us let me tell you how i look at it
differently right
is i looked at uggs i looked at
birkenstocks and i looked at crocs
together they are
three billion dollars in revenue and the
idea ultimately is
is there an opportunity to take market
share by creating a modern
cooler version of that and john buscemi
who's like a giant footwear designer
and cultural like streetwear icon
like had the vision for what it could be
to create that
then we went out and built it from
scratch right with the intent
of driving it to you know 50 million in
revenue
and try to sell it for a couple hundred
million right like that's the
that's the the the way of kind of
of looking at it versus like
how do you make the slip-on that becomes
like
how do you design it in a way that's
unique to you and your only version
that's sold through your merch and your
zone so you can go out and get it
outsourced
for six dollars and then you can sell it
for
25 and and get people to wear it all the
time because you made it a little bit
different
than what the market's offering you know
what i mean what's your unique value
proposition steve-o
well dude it's uh the the shoes
we've got this image of me [ __ ] duct
taped to a wall
so i'm actually duct taped to the shoe
okay okay okay it looks
dope as [ __ ] you want to invest in this
company
it's like for some reason my mind
flashed
to him getting kicked in the bare balls
by knoxville
and then it just i just pictured like
him getting kicked in the bare balls
with himself taped to his shoe it's like
immediately
just went like flash through my mind
and i'm still scarred i'm still scarred
by the showing me your bucket list
of skydive beats okay
i'm still scarred right in the center oh
you gotta check it out dude
thank god i did that on tv
i i wanted to ask you uh i i've had the
honor of being on ridiculousness two
separate times
uh who's been on it the most times
has anybody been on three games probably
probably like
hi brendan schaub's probably been on the
most
um you know as far as like deep
deep deep like multiple multiple but
some people been on two or three times
but nobody like
like deeply significant so i'm due for a
return
mm-hmm yeah i feel like we should just
have you on like every
you know whatever you want it's always
whenever you're in the neighborhood hey
how many submissions do you get a day on
the on your website for the videos
well that's what i'm saying we don't
take submissions right so
like we can't like so the there's a team
of people that just
basically follows everything happening
on the internet
and then sources to who posted it then
goes and gets the source footage
right because there's there's the what i
was saying about that and i'll tell you
what i i
you know when it comes to that weird
[ __ ] internet facebook hustle
[ __ ] yeah everybody's making all the
money you do it
shaq's making 500 grand a month right
whatever the [ __ ]
yeah like i've never i never did one
never
they i always felt the same way that
it's just like god it's just like you're
you're it's and it only seems to last
like a year you know what i mean six
months whatever it is
like and but that's what i was only
saying there's only a half truth in that
where we don't
take the submission right it sounds like
you invite people
into invitation only we you're invited
no we gotta go
find them they they post it anywhere we
[ __ ]
gotta like get all the way to this
you invite them to upload to your little
platform and click
i give you the rights and oh no oh no i
don't know we send you an email and you
send us the footage
you know what i'm saying we send you a
contract you send us the footage so we
have the raw
raw footage all right that's cool man
how's the uh this pig out
this um vegan pork rinds
business yeah so so uh pig out's one of
our
shining stars of our portfolio uh just
closed a
round of um 9 million raised at nearly
100 million valuation
um you know the beauty of of
uh this particular build was it's just
25 year
uh one of the chefs from the impossible
burger and like
that guy capitalist right yeah and
and they just make incredible tasting
snacks that happen to be plant-based
right
and and it's really that idea of like
they're innovating
in plant-based and when they brought it
to me originally
um you know because almost everything i
do is from the idea stage
it you know their concept was fresh soul
you know
and i was like man [ __ ] that like you
guys are so innovative
like you're making you're you're you
invented a pigless bacon chip you have a
piglet pork rind like it needs to be
more aggressive like everything in this
space is all soft it's hampton creek and
everything's all soft and
and i was like need to call it like
vegeta you know
and then then he came and hit me he's
like what do you think about pig out
and i was like oh [ __ ] i don't that's so
[ __ ] aggressive
uh and then i'm like damn and then it's
like okay and then we could be
outstanding foods and it could be pig
out then chicken out then stakeout uh
and all those things and and then um
you know that launch it was difficult to
launch with the piglets bacon chip
because it was just a one-of-one never
been done before
and then when we pivoted into the
piglets pork rind
uh it exploded right and then we just
launched takeout
which is like a puff that has all the
nutrients of an entire meal
and like a basically a delicious snack
that's like literally eating a balanced
meal and a snack
again later goodbye like it's super
innovative amazing tasting
and hopefully you know that that one
will get who knows at what level that
gets acquired at but
or we potentially might go public with
that one
which is you know a whole different ball
game
that movie ted where they like try to
sneak into tom brady's room to get his
super sperm like
i felt like they should have been
sneaking into your room to get your
super sperm down
man what the [ __ ] you on bucket list
let me say it again that i i understand
that that uh you've kind of just [ __ ]
done away with being the face of [ __ ]
you know like sure you show up and
record ridiculousness
but other than that i get the sense that
you're a very elusive
private guy and uh man it just means the
[ __ ] world to me that we got to do
this with you man it's like
i even think of it like what does durdik
get out of this he's not really
permanent it's just like we got to hang
he's going to send us a bill later
i just made 200 grand these layers are
going to get it out of us
but look i for me i just love i
know in this format it just gives me a
chance to you know
we know each other but not we've never
had a conversation
uh and i i i know how much i'd enjoy
just a great conversation
uh and that's ultimately what what i get
out of it you know what i'm saying
just a chance to connect with you after
knowing you for so many years i think
that's fair to say man like we've always
been
orbiting around each other we've
definitely had a
a history together but yeah this is our
first time just like sitting to bro down
for an hour and i [ __ ] really
appreciate it brother
yeah and if there's anything else we can
draw
like your instagram your [ __ ]
facebook like
just [ __ ] everybody hop on the dirty
train if you're not already on it
because if you're not you're blowing it
yeah eat that pig out [ __ ] i bought a
bag of pig out
at whole foods walked out of there just
[ __ ] scarfing it down i was like go
dirty
[ __ ] yes tasty tasty i'm on board
addictively delicious as we like to say
yeah so yeah man we'll let you get back
to your day and and uh congrats on your
family
the [ __ ] just being a family guy like
living the life
dude [ __ ] just setting it up dude
like you're inspiring dude and
and uh yeah i'm way behind dude but i'm
[ __ ] hustling to catch up yeah we
gotta
go yeah let's go get hypnotized hey go
to pratt but build a plan to get there
you know what i mean start at the end
what do i want it to look like in the
end then
map all those steps out and go get there
you know what i mean
yeah before you start win
sound bite we're gonna take that right
there i [ __ ] love it man hey congrats
on everything dude and thank you for
this
all right be good yeah later dude aside
from the fact that talking to rob
durdick makes me feel
really unsuccessful that was great huh
and man i love you guys who stick around
to the very end
you know it you know i love you and you
want to talk about a stocking stuffer
dude we got our hot sauce on amazon
and you know this this close to the
holidays that like
you better be ordering amazon prime i
mean i don't know i'm sure everyone else
gets it there but
amazon prime come on get yourself a
bottle of stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole at amazon yeah dude
it would mean a lot to us because we're
trying to like show amazon that we're
the real deal
so help us out and i love you thank you
so much